mayor Laszlo bogden came up with the
idea himself a contest to shovel as much
fresh compost as possible and the local
politician beats everyone else in
charity hands down me and what else do
we have to do today it said it digestion
to cover the greenhouses with sheeting
but the workers aren't there voluntarily
since the government launched its
compulsory work program for unemployed
Roma the mayor who is an ethnic Roma
himself has drafted half of the village
to work here in the greenhouses
Mnemosyne to know da mucho it to the
malacca to the office we're only have to
look each other in the eyes in the
morning when I get up the first thing
that I should ask myself is what job I
can do and not how can I best break into
a house that Frank welfare is no
solution for that Michelle K projectile
and the others we have to change things
megaphone quad does the mac care about
those new music to the ears of victor or
bonds right wing government across
hungry there are 200,000 Roma doing what
is referred to as community service but
it doesn't seem to be having as much
impact in other places as it does in
charity grinding poverty still exists in
this village 300 kilometres away three
years after the launch of the public
works program Roma feel that the scheme
discriminates against them how did you
tell efficient car we are being forced
to work like slaves we don't have
anything to eat or drink we don't even
have a toilet could we have to be
grateful otherwise we'll starve to death
chevys a shade of a attempt with bikini
the Roma get 200 euros a month for their
labor and a bundle of wood for heating
the education initiative an important
part of our bonds Romo strategy is also
not functioning the schooling for Roma
enjoy Pato remains basic and there are
no mixed classes with ethnic Hungarians
some families are coaching their kids at
home to try to bridge the difference the
Roma have long been discriminated
against in Hungarian society and things
don't seem to be improving yiannis
Farkas tells us that the new electoral
law has even restricted his civil
liberties ha in asthma middle Sagan's if
I put on these electoral forms that I'm
an ethnic Roma then I can't vote for any
of the other political parties I can
only vote for or against a Roma
representative in Parliament what is it
you get follows for the Nationals things
could be much better for the Roma in
Hungary according to Alder horvath who
says that millions of euros from the
European Union were invested in the Roma
strategy projects money that was badly
invested he says over the last 25 years
all the political parties had one thing
in common their prejudices against the
Roma community none of them really had
the will to change the situation of the
Roma ninety percent of the 700,000 Roma
live in abject poverty but only few
profit from the integration schemes the
so-called model Romo who now support for
deaths last load Bogdan and charity
isn't a member of feed ish he says it's
his objective to show the Hungarian
people that the Roma are capable of
making an honest living tilling the land
the appearance of the village at least
has improved
you